The kind of method that we are using to solve the partial differential equation,
the heat equation that is, is professionally called the finite-difference scheme,
because we are forming differences of values that fit in finite distances not infinite decimal distances.
Diagrammatically, what we are doing looks like this.
They are using the current value of our current position and the current value to its left
and the current value to its right to estimate the next value at our current position.
There are other ways for doing this. This is the most simple, but obviously, it leads to instability.
In the previous quiz, we saw that this scheme has a particular issue with this sort of function.
A function that oscillates up and down with each step in space.
So let's compute what happens with this Berry function.
Assume that this is our initial distribution of temperature.
Temperature at times 0 depending on x.
Of course, physically speaking, negative temperatures won't make sense
and particularly are not without the unit of measurement.
But now, we're doing a little mathematics.
Now, let's compute what's going to be the next temperature at x equals to 0.
The result of the first step of the temperature at time h, h is the step size, and position 0
will be its former value times 0 and position 0 plus step size times the rate of change,
and the rate of change is thermal diffusivity times the second derivative with respect to x,
which we estimate 1 over Δx².
The old temperature to the left minus Δx plus the old temperature to the right
plus Δx minus 2 times the old temperature at 0.
So what's that going to be? The old temperature at position 0 equals 1. Same here.
The old temperature to the left equals -1 and that's to the right is -1 as well.
This is 1-1-1-2, which makes -4 step size times thermal diffusivity divided by Δx².